now let's have a look at this
denominator
what on earth is this okay now just have
a look at it
the first thing you can see is that it
shares a lot in common with the
numerator see that you're still adding
up a bunch of things
you're still calculating
differences from the mean
what's different between the denominator
and the numerator
what's different
say again
okay so first there are things being
squared
but then weirdly immediately after
squaring what do you do
you take the square root
what's up with that
square root of some number being squared
now i wonder if you can think all the
way back to year 11 we actually defined
the square root of a square
it was a thing you met in the context of
graphing so far away from the world of
statistics does anyone remember what you
get when you take the square root of the
square of a number
if i put some notation here would you
remember
isn't this the absolute value if i took
a number like say negative 5
and you squared it you'd get
25 then when you take the square root
you just get
5. so in other words the fact that it
was negative before just kind of
disappears so the square root of a
square is the same as the absolute value
of that number okay
now essentially what the absolute value
is telling you is not whether you are up
or down it's telling you how far away
you are right if i said to the absolute
value of negative 5 which we just said
before is 5
what that means is
how far are you from the origin like i
don't care which direction you are
whether you're up or down i just want to
know how far you are does that make
sense
okay now why do we divide by this again
i'm trying to get at
i'm trying to answer these questions up
here why am i doing this okay
let me call your mind back to this data
do you remember what this is about
this was about
my running speed do you remember that
okay so i particularly have given you
the graph which tells me my speed okay
in kilometers per hour so you can see um
the minimum seat i'm doing is somewhere
around 12 kilometers per hour and my max
i haven't ever really hit 14 kilometers
per hour okay and just imagine this
imagine i came to you tomorrow and i
said guys guys i have such exciting news
i ran
at 15 kilometers per hour last night for
like whatever number of distance right
hopefully you would be like at least a
little bit impressed if i said i've done
15 kilometers per hour why like off the
data why would that be a suitable thing
to be happy about
yeah keegan
yeah this is not just higher this is
like a decent chunk high it's not even
on the graph actually that's how that's
how far i am from going to 15 it's not
even on my plot okay now the reason why
you can see that is because one
kilometer per hour is a lot
in comparison to my speed like it's
about ten percent isn't it ten percent
faster that's a lot of effort okay now
let's compare that to if i said okay i'm
driving on a highway i'm driving on a
highway what's the speed limit of a
highway
110 kilometers per hour on like a
federal highway right 110 kilometers per
hour you don't even feel the difference
between 110 109. do you why not
it's a smaller percentage of the total
let's come back to here right what are
you doing down here this process of
dividing through by the absolute value
this is the word that you need
this process is called standardizing
what you are trying to get a sense of is
that one kilometer per hour is it a lot
or is it a little
is it ten percent wow that's a huge
improvement or a huge like if i'm slow
if i went at a ten kilometers you're
like wow you really like dialed in you
hardly put any effort into that right
one kilometer per hour might mean a lot
or it might mean very very little but
you don't know until you compare
to what your averages are right and
that's the process of standardizing
because i can say ten percent versus one
percent i can now compare those does
that make sense it's standard across
everyone if you said like some of you i
assume much faster runners than me for
you 10 would be different right 10 but
that can be like similar something we
can compare to and that's why it's
called standardizing so this is dividing
through by magnitude
we are no longer comparing
a fast thing with a slow thing we're
comparing percentages right proportions
and that's why we can think about
something in a standard way okay
all right so let's go back up to the top
because we can answer some of these
questions now right
this is the correlation coefficient
what is the purpose of the correlation
coefficient what is it trying to do and
the answer is it's trying to say if we
have a look at a whoopsie does he
if we have a look at a data set it's
trying to say how much do all of those
data points deviate from the mean let me
write that down for you okay this is
about how much
do all the data points i guess a word we
could use for that
for all the data points is we could say
collectively like i'm trying to consider
them all together
how much do they collectively
deviate go up and down or you know be a
distance away
from the mean
and again when i say mean
i actually
should say means because there's one for
x and one for y but you get the idea
okay
now how does it mathematically achieve
that purpose well let's have a look at
what's going on here in the formula
right
firstly it calculates some differences
right calculates x differences and y
differences
multiplies them together to get a single
number
and then you add that for every single
data point okay so what it does is it
adds
all the differences from the mean
and then what was that denominator doing
the word we used was it
standardizes so we can actually compare
these things so every correlation
coefficient you will see every r you
will see is between negative one
and one which is like a percentage right
negative 100
all the way to 100 you can't get any
bigger or smaller than that so it adds
all the differences from the mean in a
standardized way
okay